alors que la plupart de leurs camarades
dans encore cinq jeunes nageurs sont
déjà pris pour leur entraînement matinal
dès les premières lueurs du jour le
coach passe les récupérer une discipline
de fer pour réaliser les meilleures
performances
j'aime nager et oignons un peu obligé de
le faire un pur a mis du temps à l'est
où tu veux voyager des lycéens aux mots
hésitants à peine réveillé mais qui se
donne les moyens pour atteindre leur
objectif se qualifier pour des
compétitions de haut niveau et sur la
plage du carbet à 6 heures du matin les
jeunes sportifs ont l'avantagé d'avoir
la plage rien pour eux je vais vous
demander du 4 nages sur la part à tina
j'ai donc souple mais en 4 nages
ces nageurs ont tous choisi d'intégrer
le centre d'accession et de formation au
lycée de bellefontaine
le caf doit permettre à ces lycéens
d'allier études et sport de haut niveau
quand on commence à être en terminale et
où on n'a plus trop le temps de manger
et tout est comme la les emplois du
temps sont adaptés tout ça on a des on
peut avoir des cours de rattrapage et
tout donc c'est plus facile de venir
manger afin de coordonner les deux le
dispositif mis en place par la
fédération française de natation vise à
préparer les futurs grands nageurs
français
un cahier des charges doit être respecté
par les ligues
l'objectif donner à ses nageurs les
mêmes chances de réussite
c'est une sculpture d'excellence donc
tout est mise à disposition comme je
disais le kiné le ch'ti aux pattes
les milices les créneaux d'entraînement
et sur le plan school et un bain ils ont
des aménagements d'emploi du temps de
façon à rattraper des cours ou des
devoirs sur des créneaux libres
le lycée de bellefontaine met tout en
place pour respecter le rythme soutenu
des jeunes nageurs en internat ils
débutent les cours plus tard que les
autres et les professeurs reviennent le
soir pour attraper les leçons un pôle
d'excellence qui doit permettre de
former une élite de la natation
française sans sacrifier leur réussite
scolaire